>> ERIN McKEAN: DARE—the Dictionary of American
Regional English—really represents the idea
that every word of American English is worth
study, is worth investigation, and all speakers
deserve to have their language recorded.
>> EMILY ARKIN: At a high level, DARE as a
dictionary is a project that really shows
a snapshot of what America is like.
It has a very long history, going back to
the early 20th century, based on a large-scale
survey that involved differences between different
regions and how people used the same language.
>> ERIN McKEAN: The most exciting part of
the new digital edition of DARE is that it
offers so many more ways to get into the books.
>> EMILY ARKIN: It took several years of brainstorming,
and a lot of thinking about what new things
we could do in new media and with web technology.
>> ERIN McKEAN: They’ve made a lot of the
data more accessible along different axes.
>> EMILY ARKIN: There’s the dictionary A
to Z, which has the entries and all of their
definitions and many different senses.
Then there’s also the survey data behind
the scenes, so you can really dig into the
background of the dictionary that way.
>> ERIN McKEAN: Now you can look and see,
“oh, okay well what words are used in a
particular region,” “what’s the constellation
of terms used for a particular thing.”
>> EMILY ARKIN: We have access to all of the
audio recordings, so you can hear audio as
you’re going through the dictionary with
examples.
>> FIELD RECORDING: “Hush puppies, well
that’s like ham and eggs.
Eggs go with ham, hush puppies go with fish.”
>> ERIN McKEAN: The experience of flipping
through a paper dictionary, finding what you
want and then finding a whole bunch of things
that you didn’t know that you wanted, that
serendipity is really important.
>> EMILY ARKIN: We did try to capture some
of that serendipity in the website.
We have a word wheel, so that you can spin
it and see, “oh, I’ve never heard that
word before,” or maybe you’re looking
at one word in the alphabet and you see ten
that are nearby.
>> ERIN McKEAN: The ability to personalize
your DARE experience, save what you’ve looked
up, really make DARE your own, is one of the
things that make people feel that a dictionary
belongs to them, it’s their tool, it’s
there for what they need.
>> EMILY ARKIN: If you’re doing a really
specific sociological study, or maybe you
just want to find out how your own grandmother
spoke, there’s a lot of power to find exactly
the word you’re looking for.
>> ERIN McKEAN: Every time you put something
online it’s a new and brave undertaking.
How will a scholar use this, how will a researcher
use this, how will an elementary school student
who’s writing a report use this.
It’s going to open up DARE to new uses that
we haven’t even thought of yet.
And that’s what makes me really excited
about the digital edition of DARE.